رحله العوده الى كراماتسك الصغار والكبار
يعودون ادراجهم بعدما تمكنت القوات
الاوكرانيه من استعاده مناطقها محطه
القطار اقتصت ايضا بالجنود الذين جاءوا
للقاء احبائهم
فالنتينا تبلغ من العمر 85 عاما نزحت الى
شرق اوكرانيا منذ بدء الغزو الروسي
لبلادها وبقيت هناك حوالي سبعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
هامرت بالبكاء رغم الدمار الهائل الذي
خلفها الروس في منطقتها وصفات الانذار
قررت عدم التخلي عن منزلها حتى لو هذا
القصف هو سقطت المباني افضل ان اموت في
منزله من هذه القريه الصغيره في شمال
مدينه شبهها مدمره من دون ماء ولا كهرباء
بدا سكانها اعاده الترميم وقرروا ان
يباتوا ليلتهم هناك وبما ان الجسر الذي
يربطه المدينه بالجوار مهدمه وجدو الحل في
هذا القارب الصغير لشراء الطاقه
كله اوكرانيا مناضل بدل قصار جهده من اجل
بلده
المدنيون من نساء واطفال جميعهم كانوا
يؤمنون بالنصر وبعوده
استعاده هذه المنطقه الجنوبيه ساد الفرح
بعد اشهر من الاحتلال رغم الدمار الذي
خلفته القواته الروسيه